gence laboratory at MIT he sat down with
scott kirsner of the Boston Globe to
discuss his new book flesh and machines
it chronicles the development of
robotics looks to a future with sentient
machines and considers a host of ethical
problems this could create it's an hour
and five minutes I'm still trying to
figure out which one of us is FDR up
here right well I'm the one thing is the
fire is real it's the fire is real and
in fact I brought in case we need a
snack later on I brought some some
marshmallows and I think we need some
fun with some long Forks if someone
could go look for those um it's it's
really great to actually have you here
and help us launch this series and I'm
really excited to have this hour to to
chat with you and I guess I want to
thank mimic and Nixon Peabody for
putting on this event may be a good
place to start is just to talk a little
bit about your childhood in your
background you grew up in Adelaide
Australia which sounds interesting and
exotic to all of us here in Boston tell
us a little bit about that and also
about what brought you to to the states
and what got you interested in robotics
well I was interested in robotics back
in Adelaide Australia it Adelaide's a
town about halfway across the continent
on the south coast and much more
isolated than just about any town or
city in in the United States and for
some reason and I can't explain it I was
always interested in trying to build
computers I've never seen a computer but
I was trying to build computers and
ultimately I started trying to build
robots when I was a kid when I was still
in high school and then I the vertel
into pure mathematics is was no
engineering school nearby but ultimately
I started applying to graduate schools
in the United States did not get into
MIT but did get into Stanford actually
got into Stanford and Carnegie Mellon so
I went in town that was to look up where
they work they had no clue
and we still don't know where Pittsburgh
yes that's right so that's that's how I
ended up at Stanford and then they got
to work on computer vision and like
finally ultimately robots again so when
you say you were building computers and
robots as a kid I mean how old were you
was it a solitary pursuit or was it
something you did with a group of
friends oh no it was entirely solitary I
was about eight years old when I started
by the time i was 12 i built this this
machine out of old tell them you know
there's telephone switching things that
used to have for the receptionist where
you know a little business with the
little eyeballs metal things that would
come down and 3-way switches because i
built a machine out of those old
components that I get which could play
tic-tac-toe and and and would always win
but I didn't quite have enough
components so it it couldn't do
arbitrary rotations and reflections it
would always go first in the middle and
then the person who was playing it had
to choose the top left corner or the top
middle and every adult I showed it to
would say well I want to choose the
bottom right corner I'd say oh it's just
the same and rotate it for him I said oh
no no I want to it was really
frustrating we thought you were conning
them they thought that was coming in
with fans and how about the first robot
well actually that was inspired by I
don't know people probably haven't heard
of a guy named w gray volta he was an
actually an American who worked at the
burden neurophysiological Institute in
Bristol England in the late 1940s and
early 1950s looking at brain waves and
he came up with all sorts of discoveries
about human brainwaves but he also
brought some little robots that he
called tortoises which were built it was
very English the way it worked it you
know take it took about gas meters to
get gears and put them together and it
had to they'd had to vacuum tubes it's
very simple circuit but I had a lot of
interesting behavior one of them in fact
is on display at the MIT museum now and
I'd read about these when I was a kid he
published in Scientific American in 1950
1951 and you could get scientific
american in adelaide that way yeah there
was no was that way in the library yeah
and so with that I started trying to go
the robot based on that but i was using
transistors not
to not vacuum tubes and said you had
these little tortoises running around
your house running one in the house the
one that I dealt was called Norman and
it would sort of would follow lights and
it would wander around and bumped into
something would move away but chairs
four-legged chairs were a real trap for
it would find its way in and then
couldn't get out and so that's what it
was fun to see and how do people react
how did your parents react how did
people your age react when you well you
had this interest they what I was that
you know they didn't know the word geek
but that's what they thought I was that
were right haha yeah and so when you
left do you go back to Adelaide
occasionally are you about no I go back
to Adelaide ah every year at least yeah
um i guess i'm curious to maybe an
interesting place to start is to talk a
little bit about robots in pop culture
and whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing i'm sure it must have been some
way influenced you as you were studying
and doing research to see robots and
Star Wars and Star Trek and forbidden
planet and just all of the
representations of these these huge you
know tin can like things Islam is one
all the time yeah yeah absolutely in
fact 2001 a Space Odyssey came out when
I was around 15 actually I read the book
slightly before I saw the movie and that
was a really big influence on me because
finally I saw someone else you know
there's some other view in the world of
robots and intelligent you know how
happened to be a murdering psychopath
but apart from that small detail how was
really intelligent has that set you off
under particular trajectory is nothing
wrong though not a little level uh-huh
so you saw two thousand i guess i'm
curious do you feel like in most
people's minds have the robots that we
see in pop culture whether it's Hal or
c-3po or Rosie the robot made on the
Jetsons do you feel like that's had a
good influence or a bad influence well
you know obviously Hollywood wants a
good story and they've been two major
questions that have been pursued by
Hollywood and this doesn't include Rosie
from the Jetsons but the two major
questions are if these robots get really
intelligent will we accept them so c-3po
one acceptance commander data on start
want acceptance the robot that in
Bicentennial man played by robin
williams robin williams wanted
acceptance that was his quest and the
other question is will they want to take
over from us which is the Terminator the
Forbin project you know that we you know
we we create these these entities we
nurture them we help them we teach them
they start to get bit smarter and
smarter they start to think that we're
not so smart after all and can't wait to
get rid of us this is not our teenagers
this is the robots ah but it's the same
thing you know it's I think I think
that's probably you know in some sense
where that theme comes from in Hollywood
well it's an analogy because I think you
say in the book like teenagers robots
once they actually break off from us
will maybe down the road start to treat
us a little more kindly and look at us
benevolently as though those crazy old
humans yeah well you know I but I'm not
too worried and I don't think we're
gonna have to face robots being that
smart in the near term as I talk about
in the book I think we're going to
become much more like robots before they
become like us by putting technology and
our bodies but I think there's a lot of
interesting stuff happens before that
where you know I sort of think that
we're in in computer years it's about
1978 1979 in for robots back then you
might remember the first robot the first
computers start with getting to our
houses as you know the little micro
process is in the game pong for instance
and so this that computers started to
get into our everyday lives as games
those space invaders which was really
popular and in around 78 79 the first
few home computers were around but you
had to be to be pretty dedicated to use
them right then so the same things
happening with robots we've got the
first few robots in our homes Furby was
was a simple robot 38 million I think of
those was sold and then there's other
robot toys I've got one down here if you
want to look at it yeah let's have a
look though so
there's that this is this is a this is a
calm a real baby and this was developed
by a local company that I'm chairman of
irobot Helen greener is the president
over there and common angles CEO and
this was this was developed in
conjunction with Hasbro and there was
actually on the market Christmas before
last so you know as you can see the
robot it's a robot but it's a it's a toy
it's for its for kids I never know what
it's going to do something you know one
time one time it woke up and fired right
right wetin let's let's see if tickle
its foot and see if it was sure was fun
is this is available this toy people can
buy it or or was it it had added season
toys go through seasons and then oh no
she's working but there's other toys
lots of other companies and and our
company developing lots of toys oh I
guess that's prompted by crowds in
campus look look see if you take the
bottle she might respond to that so what
are some of the behaviors that are
designed into that um well she's got
she's on emotions now you might say it's
an emotional emotional in quotes model
oh she's dirty oh I'm not there's a baby
changing area you know it's a good thing
about my real baby it's that that
changing is not real and it's only
virtual p and you only have to virtually
change it that then things should be a
little better so when you say emotions
in quotes you mean stay a little bit
more about that you mean it has kind of
emotional or routines it it has a set of
variables inside which specify an
emotional state and depending what
emotional state at gym
she will respond differently to the same
action so if she's sort of happy and I'm
bouncing her up and down she'll get
happier but if she's already upset my
start bouncing up and down that may not
be too much fun Cora I say in quotes
because I'm not sure anyone here or even
me is willing to say it's real emotions
but in principle I think it's possible
to build robots ultimately with real
emotions I hesitated as I said that well
because people probably jump in a lot at
that point and say well we're the only
things that can have real emotions they
can simulate emotions yeah the other
nice thing about this baby the off
switch yeah I want to talk about that
that thing about people jumping in and
seeing the only thing you can have real
emotions you know garry kasparov World
Chess Champion was beaten by deep blue
two three four years ago I don't know
exactly the date right now and after he
was beaten he said something to the
effect that I never quite exactly right
but some of you think well at least it
didn't enjoy beating me so you know he
was the world chess champion had just
got beaten what he had as his item of
pride was that he had emotions and deep
blue didn't have emotions and deep blue
certainly didn't have anything like
emotions it was a brute forced research
program so he'd lost that intellectual
battle but he wasn't a cold hard machine
he had emotions and you know with we as
humans have had to give up and was
retreat from our positions of our
specialness multiple times through
history 500 years ago the earth was this
place that God had made for mankind and
we were at the center of the ue was a
center of the universe the earth the Sun
went around the earth and then we've got
Leo we discovered that well the earth
went around the Sun and so did the other
planets it wasn't so special and over
time we discovered there were lots of
other solar systems other Suns other
galaxies etc it was pretty hard for the
church to accept that but the church did
accept that and survived that but we
lost that specialness of our place in
the universe and then 150 years ago with
Darwin we lost our special
as being different from the animals we
were the same we became the same as
animals and so over time as our
understanding of universes as improved
we have lost parts of our specialness
and we keep hiding behind various
barriers of what makes us special but we
keep getting beaten again again over the
head you know last year when the Human
Genome Project sort of announced that
there were 35 thousand genes in the
human genome those outraged only 35,000
genes we're better than that right
there's slime ball that is right exactly
so you know I think I think the people
was this idea over the last 40 or 50
years we've given up just piece by piece
the claim we're superior the machines in
calculating and and reasoning I remember
a book that i had in adelaide when i was
a kid it was about giant brains and it
described computers and almost great
great source of my knowledge of
computers have never actually seen one
but it said it was an american book it
had their but chinese-american recently
beat a giant brain with his record his
an abacus and so there they were
clinging to this that a human could
still be a computer a calculating well
we've we've given up on that you know
over the last 40 years we know the
computers can multiply and add fast and
us right and in robots on the assembly
line we're happy saying okay they're
better welders than human beings right
better accuracy and and everyone except
maybe a few astronauts so you know the
flight control system can land the
airplane or land the shuttle better than
a than a human camp but what we've got
left is out of our specialness is that
we have emotions and that that non
living systems don't have emotions and
so in the book you say you think robots
may be able to have emotions that they
may be able to have spirituality they
may surpass humans in intelligence if
they haven't already well what I yeah
what I say is that we are machines and I
think that's the sort of unstated
assumptions
all of modern molecular biology that we
are biological machines made of
biomolecules which interact according to
laws of physics and chemistry and that's
all there is that's that's what makes us
but we don't sort of think about us
ourselves as machines too much but if we
are machines that in principle in
principle it certainly seems to me that
you could have another machine which
wasn't us which had emotions you know in
the in the in principle you could just
build a copy of us molecule by molecule
that would be the same and it would have
emotions although some philosophers John
Searle at Berkeley for instance argue no
it wouldn't be even it was identical to
us it wouldn't have emotions because it
wouldn't have the historical context
that this body has from the the germ
line but so in principle it seems
possible to build machines with emotions
and this one is you know this one is
something you can buy a toy store but
the robots that that we have in our labs
which I talk about have much more
sophisticated emotional models they're
not they're not things that can be
reduced to a toy price right now but
maybe in the future they will be able to
be and they're the question of do they
have real emotions or not is a little
harder to answer a lot of people maeve
subjects that we test with the robot
certainly interact with the robot as
though it has real emotions for periods
of minutes at a time and the graduate
students who built the robot find
themselves interacting with it as though
they have emotions so ultimately I guess
I'm curious that I mean people must sort
of jump on you as being the messenger of
this end of specialness when you come
out and say in public forums well I
don't really think we're special because
we have emotions and we have feelings
and we have these sensitivities and
reactions people must jump on you and
say you know kind of a shoot the
messenger type of reaction let's sit in
that reaction and the other reaction is
ah ok so those robots going to have
emotions back but they don't have spirit
yes that's it we have spirit or now
they're not going to be conscious we
have consciousness so I think we're a
barrier after barrier yeah
you know we're going to be manning the
ramparts defending our specialness piece
by piece and these are not easy things
to first to go up I mean evolution it's
been 150 years and there's still lots of
places in this country and elsewhere of
it where people arguing specifically
about the correctness of that not
anywhere Cambridge thought you mean okay
out of hats right what do I guess so the
assumption that you want us to make is
that we're not we're not special in any
way I don't necessarily want you to make
that assumption but that's that's what
I'm stating and in the book i show how
to build robots with properties of
living systems out of simple lawful
interactions and when the complexity of
those becomes enough it becomes in
distilling indistinguishable from a
living system and so I think you
mentioned it before and I think you
talked about it in the book you're less
it seems like maybe you're less
interested in these autonomous robots
that exist that are kind of built from
the ground up out of tinker toys or
processors and you're more interested or
maybe you see that there's some more
potential in human beings kind of
becoming a human / robots are kind of a
hybrid yeah I think I think that's a
reality that's going on here we've been
pushing robots and robot technologies
coming wet right along its you know I
was sort of going with the analogy
before of nineteen seventy eight years
and we're starting to see domestic
robots lon mining robots from friendly
machines cleaning robots from Electrolux
so there's those sorts of robots coming
along and will be useful will be adopted
but I don't think we're going to get the
building something as good as commander
data from star trek in the in the near
term but at the same time as with you
know some of us are pushing in that
direction this is other push to get
silicon and steal technology in our
bodies lots of people are walking around
with cochlear implants where there's
direct neural connections from
electronics implant in their ear so they
can hear people on death there's
quadriplegics who have brain damage very
high
on this phone who can't control anything
but their eyes they can't do a puff and
sip controller but people that had
implants in their brain so they can
think and move a mouse under thought
control so they're those quadriplegics
now have a little tiny bit of
independence tiny bit of independence
they can browse the web by themselves
and they can send email and receive
email there's other lots of other things
going on retinal implants or big area of
research they haven't been gotten the
point of clinical success yet but for
people with macular degeneration I you
know who's going to argue if we can
build a silicon retina put it in there I
and they'll be able to have some
mobility and from being able to see I
think that people agree that's a
worthwhile thing to do it right but as
these technologies get developed then I
think people are going to want to start
augmenting their body not because of
some disease or some active volunteer
sir it's like like plastic surgery
plastic surgery started out you know
fixing cleft palates fixing severe burns
and that was a whole industry of people
who buy some normal sort of standard are
perfectly okay who are augmenting their
body changing the way their body looks
so for instance i think his a path for
how it might happen if retinal implants
become successful and there are clinical
trials going on which may or may not be
successful now but I think there's so
much push that they will ultimately be
successful you know imagine in a few
years you've got macular degeneration
and you can buy this retinal implant and
the r300 model lets you see just
normally but if you pay an extra 500
bucks for the hour 400 model you get
under thought control just like these
quadriplegics right now who's movements
and the thought control you get to
retune your retina to see in the
infrared to have night vision okay just
an extra 500 bucks now I've got night
vision to right and as ray specs I know
that's how much that's the 500 model I
have a good yeah you could go places I'm
in advertising the back of comic books
so so you know once that comes along
then maybe someone who doesn't have
macular degeneration says gee I'd like
to have that night vision or maybe
Special Forces want to have night vision
or so I think we'll be pushes to use
these technologies for augmentation and
I think that's going to cascade along
fairly quickly you know in the 10 20 30
year time frame and so while we're
trying to make our robot smarter and
smarter for some purposes but they'll be
plenty of robots for useful everyday
stuff that are going to be all around us
the really smart really really human
level smart robots going to be hard but
in the meantime we're going to be
bringing the technologies for those
regular robots into our bodies they're
better vision systems the better hearing
systems the the wireless internet
connection implanted somewhere in our
brain so you know our grandchildren when
we talk to them and that they sort of
the sort of spaced out they've got six
simultaneous chat connections going
everybody who cares what we say right
right instant messaging kind of as a
weight of tuning you out right well and
it will change the whole way we do we do
business just the way first the
Telegraph changed the way business was
done internationally than the telephone
and they have a cell phone when we have
instant access to large databases and to
communication the way we interact with
each other is going to change we don't
have all these other channels going on
invisibly so I mean it just you know
where we've had sort of other kinds of
augmentation in the past you're talking
about intellect entation organization
that can make me have a thesaurus or an
encyclopedia yeah the next into our
neural system and I'm and there's
technical details of how to do this but
we see the first few versions of this so
I think it's inevitable what's going to
happen then we might decide I mean
there's gonna be all sorts of
interesting questions yeah i was gonna
ask me do you feel like they're gonna be
some societal impacts here that we
haven't seen yet with people getting
nose jobs and breast augmentation and
things yeah well we've seen them in
other ways but you know will it be will
be okay for a kid to take the SATs with
their wireless internet connection
switched on you know i have to prove
that it's switched off or you know 20
years ago probably you know you won't
allowed to have a calculator
in an essay tea now it's expected to
have a calculator so 40 years from now
will it be expected that every kid has a
wireless in the connection if that wow
it's internet connection if they're
taking the SATs well we come to expect
these augmentations in the same way we
expect use of other technology you know
just because you you know I can't see
the board either because you're not
wearing glasses and I get glasses right
we expect kids to be able to get glass I
guess so do you think at all about the
the societal impact here I mean there's
an interesting article in The New York
Times study about these implantable
defibrillators and the cost you know I
think it's something like 20,000 for the
device and then 10,000 to have it
implanted you know to keep you alive if
your heartbeat becomes irregular if your
heart is on the verge of stopping you
know it seems like that's creating
already class issues in terms of you
know Dick Cheney can afford one of those
but you know someone living in the
projects might not be able to yeah well
I mean the same is true of old
technologies televisions when they first
came out were were a luxury item there
now considered that everyone in the
projects you know has a right to have a
TV the prices come down cell phones were
incredibly expensive you know in the
early days and now that that in our
society they're free and in almost and
and they've even infiltrated large parts
of the third world in ways where there
was no intervening communication system
so I say thank all technologies do start
up being just for the wealthy but you
know there's a standard law of
manufacturing as you increase the amount
manufactured the price goes down so this
is not a new thing particularly with
these technologies it's a thing with all
technologies so you don't see that we
that's talking about the class issue but
you don't see there's no one big
conflict or one big problem that you see
being created by you know these
voluntary implants that people might get
in their brains or all the reasonably
all sorts of unforeseen implants gonna
be all sorts of secondary and tertiary
effects we're not we're not going to
know about them till they start
happening it's going to be very hard to
predict the the mass effects of these
but you can be sure that there will be
some things so what are some of the
things that you think about well I'm
talk about the unforeseen things
well you know maybe it's gonna maybe
it's gonna change our whole sex lives I
don't know you know it's interesting you
mentioned to me thanks for segue into
sex oh you mentioned to me that your
publisher said to you you know there's
not enough sex in this book well he said
the agent said that to you is that I had
to put some sex in the book so there's
one paragraph in which but they're
encouraging you the next book should be
about know that I haven't poem okay I
you know the I I do want to get you to
talk about that a little bit because
books I wissen i was watching the movie
the Steven Spielberg movie a I recently
and one of the robots in that movie Joe
gigolo Joe yeah is basically a
prostitute robot and at one point he
says once you've had a lover robot
you'll never want a real man again and
you know not that I have any problems in
that department but I'm curious you know
what a you know is that something that
you thought about is you know internet
on the internet you know sex and
pornography seems to be kind of the main
engine oh well it was sex in that
section pornography have been big
drivers for many technologies for the
Humvee CI market that was a big big
driver and still as a major the
production of that sort of material
storm as equals Hollywood in size and
it's been a major driver on the the
internet and I expect that we will see
things in in in robotics in fact after i
was on NPR the other day i got email
from someone saying hey you didn't
reference us and our site and you know
simply appointed to a robotic sex site
where you can buy product today so
there's already some people out there so
there's no research going on at MIT
people out people elsewhere are taken
care of yeah let's yeah tell us about
some of the things we talked about
humans kind of um starting on the path
to becoming robots talk about robots
just as pure machines and I'm sure one
of the first things that people always
ask you is well what about the robot
that will clean my house you know and do
all these other tasks that we don't like
to do with what's kind of the near term
and maybe then the longer the really
neat term is that you can now buy a
robot if you live in Sweden
will clean the floors of your house
their floors already clean right I mean
it's it's Sweden right well it's
Electrolux is selling one right now but
other companies unannounced and talked
about selling them soon and I think
you're going to see more and more of
them on the market there's been a lot of
prototypes and a lot of different
companies so you'll see more and more of
them over the the next couple of years
so they're the right now those robots
are succeeding by giving up the old idea
getting to a price point which is
perhaps affordable by giving up the idea
of doing a going over the floor in a
very ordered orderly sort of fashion so
this Electrolux robot you switch it on
and it goes around the edges but then it
sort of goes randomly in the middle and
over time picks up the dirt so the first
few robots that we see home cleaning
robots are going to be like that which
is going to be a little too annoying for
some people I had one of the friendly
machines lawn mowing robots at my house
and it uses the same random patent is a
wire around the edge of the law and it
goes around that then randomly searches
isn't that how you mow the lawn now I
mean I'm either gonna be on that well
you know the guy that normally mode our
lawns for us in nice straight lines you
know came by and he didn't know that we
had this robot enables he said guess I'm
not out of a job yet and my wife agreed
with him completely because it was
random lines on the lawn so so that was
this an experiment you're not using that
on a on a weekly basis now uh no it was
but it was an interesting experiment and
we had it for a while but it here's the
thing here's the thing i'm gonna diverge
what the big failure mode for it was
that it ran out of batteries and just
SAT there and so I to put a long as I
went to work and after two hours run out
of batteries don't just sit there
waiting for someone to come and and
drive it it still had a little bit of
battery left enough to be driven back
the recharging station it would have
been much better if it to get the
recharging station itself but that
implies an awful lot of smarts that
we're not going to see in the robot soon
but what it would have been
and for this audience especially as an
internet connection so it worked I could
have just row bottled into it and driven
it back to get recharged and then let it
go for another couple of hours out
hacking away at the lawn instead of
having it spread over multiple days so
this whole idea of having internet
control of robots remote presence I
think is going to lead to all sorts of
interesting applications and there's a
bunch of companies around including a
robot who are experimenting in the
commercial domain with with robots out
there with with companies where people
use a web browser they connect to a
robot somewhere else and then they
become that robot so I medio you're in
Boston I need to inspect some piece of
equipment in Phoenix there's like your
robot there that was a robot there I go
I you go drive it around look at the
piece of equipment talk to the people
out there you know just sit there as a
robot talking to them they have to sort
of pay attention to its not like in
teleconferencing we're just the screen
over you've got a real presence people
know who you're looking at because the
robots looking around at them making eye
contact and the engineer here can be
assured of what's going on it isn't just
restricted to living in that box in the
conference room that can follow everyone
around see what's happening kick the
tires for themselves and so these sorts
of applications are starting to spring
up but the real application I think the
real driver for this ultimately I think
is going to be Japan Japan has an aging
population they do not import labor and
so they're really pushing on this the
idea of remote presence to have people
in other countries provide some of the
nerving nursing services by robots in
Japan so you get this whole idea of work
being exported to other countries and
it's not the physical labor that you're
exporting you you're renting the brains
of smart people in other come on the
same way that a US company might
outsource some of their programming work
to India exactly and but now it's now
it's in a slightly less skilled arena
where anyone you know who can see
objects and recognize them which is hard
for our robots
can provide the high-level intelligence
this robot to do some manual task in
another country so I think that could be
ended up being a real driver for robots
in everyday society that export of
waiver I want to just ask one more thing
and then we'll open it up to some
questions from the audience talk a
little bit about what kind of research
are you doing right now at the
artificial intelligence lab at MIT and
what directions are you pursuing what's
kind of the new stuff for you at the AI
lab well hey I labs over 20 faculty
there's lots of things going on I'll
tell you two stories one is professor
tom night and then I'll talk about my
own work a little bit tom has been
taking a simple programming language if
you like and set of compiling programs
to run on regular computers it compiles
them into a DNA string splices the DNA
into an e coli genome cooks up 10 to the
12th little ecoli with this piece of DNA
in them and when the RNA transcription
mechanism reads off that piece of DNA it
does the digital computation which was
specified by the original program now
this is not to make computers in
bacteria the purpose of it is to get
digital control over something that's
happening inside bacteria it's very slow
in fact it runs it 16 hundredth of a
hertz but so intelligent you're running
scared no but it gives digital control
over something in a self-reproducing
self-repairing biological system and so
I think the long-term impact of this and
when you couple that with these cells
are able to send messages to each other
by lactone molecules just as cells on a
zebra send messages to each other to
figure out who should be the white
stripes and who should be the black
stripes they're not all speckled
together they ought self-organized the
art you know with just a few
technological breakthroughs in 50 years
from now instead of growing a tree
cutting it down and building a chair
will just grow a chair by engineering to
the biotechnology that we see the day is
very crude compared to where I think we
are going to ultimately end up
and then our biological interest at an
industrial infrastructure will be
largely biological and we not real mixed
up with who we are and that's going to
be a whole other thing to worry about my
own work I've been building with my
students humanoid robots for the last 10
years but every 10 years I sort of have
a midlife research crisis and I had one
last year so the new thing I'm doing is
really stems from this question of
whether will robots really have emotions
loop because they ever be real emotions
every wondering what does it mean for
something to be really alive what would
it take to build a living machine do we
understand the processes of living in
enough detail that we could build a
machine which we would be comfortable
saying is alive or have them has the
properties of living organisms so how is
that manifesting itself so far well
we've got a three-pronged attack we're
building standards build robots that
have capabilities that living systems
have but robots previously haven't had
like self repair self reproduction
metabolism a few other things like that
I think one of the things you talk about
in the book is or we talked about a
previous conversation is kind of robots
that would be able to find their own
energy sources let's have a robot being
able to find out our outlet yeah exactly
we've got one robot right now but that
is able to go and find that fine wall
sockets and plug itself in I actually
actually want to build a robot vermin
that hides that comes out and steals the
electricity at night but it doesn't have
an off switch but so that the here's how
we see that how Hal has influenced your
career the second thrust is is building
large-scale computational experiments
some people might call them simulations
but not simulate anything real
investigating questions like how did
prebiotic chemistry self-organize into
living systems and what emulating real
chemistry we're trying to abstract out
some of the combinatorial properties and
building simulations or experiments like
that and the third thrust is for my grad
students to be building these things
look at them have deep mathematical
insights and state improved wonderful
deep theorems and
has happened yet that third part but
we're only a year or a few months into
this money will read into it so any
decade now something will happen all
right well let's if there are some
questions in the audience I'd love to
take a few of those raise your hand and
we'll get a microphone to you there in
the back wow you thank you for a
fascinating discussion it's almost 60 s
like turns units in fact I've got two
questions on the emotional robots oh and
there's somewhat related ones about sex
and the others about religion if a robot
I mean as humans the belief is is that
we have a drive toward sex because we're
trying to procreate the species it's a
genetic drive at least is understood
some of my key to comment memory
Kerswell sport and your opinion to that
but some of what I believe Kurzweil is
proposing is is that if you essentially
mimic a particular human in a digital
form that human will essentially evolved
in the same way this as the human would
have evolved but of course when it comes
to things like sex it might not involve
quite the same way because if it
involves in the human form obviously
it's not going to mate with another
human but if it evolved in the robotic
form it might think that something like
a manufacturing plant would be
something that would procreate similarly
in religion it would seem to me that
most religions a lot of religions other
than pagan keep on looking for worship
of the Creator and there's an awful lot
of intensity around the Creator if the
emotional human that or the emotional
robot that was evolved out of a human
would it be worshipping the Creator as
you or would it be worshipping the
Creator that the human would have
worshipped those are some great
questions I've been asked to if you can
restate all of those questions in your
answer although I'll receipts some of
I'd like you to refer mr. Landry you
want to do your reaction to rakers wells
book the age of spiritual spiritual
machines talk a little bit about maybe
technol technological cloning sort of
putting ourselves into robots and I'm
really summarizing here and also talk
about this notion of will robots do you
want robots to worship you that you
create no first person let me talk about
ray's book and i sort of a sort of polka
tray in my book you know ray and Hans
Moravec and other people have talked
about being able to ultimately download
ourselves into computers so we can live
forever and if you if you look at when
they when they predict that will happen
it's typically about when they're 70 in
raised case it's a little older than
when he's 70 but he's a healthy guy he's
a healthy guy he's actually published a
book on how to live longer through
better diet and so I think there's a
certain wishful thinking their wish for
immortality that people are sort of
projecting onto you don't have that same
way that there will be some robot that
you can porch yourself over right I
don't think that that's going to happen
any you know that might ultimately
happen but I think there's so many
things that we don't understand about
our bodies in the in the world that just
being able to capture the patterns of
activity in our brains as ray talks
about with nanotechnology which has some
other issues about whether that's
possible
and being able to recreate them in the
machine i don't think that might that
necessarily leads to a very satisfying
existence similar to our corporal
existence so you know the possibility of
though that entity will wake up feeling
really unhappy about it about it's the
way it exists to try and answer some of
the other questions that the speaker
talked about we have to be a little
careful not not to project too much
under these robots from humans if we're
just building intelligent robots because
they will be different than us
ultimately why is it that we as humans
do have so many religions where there is
a creator I don't know why that is we
had someone a Lutheran minister on a
first in our research group at MIT for a
few years actually to exactly think
about this question what is it about the
way humans are structured which may make
them quest for that so we would
understand that part of our humanity is
we're trying to build the robots and
even put it in on that put them I don't
see a na priori reason that we would
want to put that into our robots and so
I think we'll probably choose not to
although who knows I think that mr.
Landry also was asking what robots have
this reproductive Drive well they want
to reproduce with other robots with well
you know we we have a reproductive Drive
because if we didn't we wouldn't be here
and so the things that did other things
that Darwinian evolution selected for
because they're the ones that reproduced
robots have we are going to have a
rather different relationship to their
DNA then we have to put our DNA our DNA
is encapsulated inside ourselves the
robots dmae its wiring diagrams its
circuitry its software can be stored in
backup storage that's a very different
sort of
meant that of existence and procreation
so we may have not have any of the sorts
of drives that that natural selection is
selected for a mass they may not be
necessary and just to kind of come back
to the last that the last part of that
question when people say are you doing
this because you have some sort of god
complex how do you know you know and how
do you address the issue of why you know
why are you doing this why you should
try to create biological robots and yeah
autonomous intelligent robots you know
I've got lots of rational intellectual
reasons and and and and then I've got
lots of other reasons that I tell the
sponsors you know you know because
you're going to be able to build better
this because it's going to increase
productivity that way what did the
intellectual reasons are the personal
well the intellectual reasons are you
know that I'm trying to understand how
it is that humans operate so this is an
experimental methodology which
interfaces with neuroscience cognitive
science it's the philosophy etc but the
truth no matter when I was eight years
old back in Australia I like to you know
make these machines and switch them on
and have them you know have their own
autonomy and their own reason for being
now people have attributed different
things to me at different times about
why I do this in the 80s people would
come up to me and say reporters would
say are you are doing this because you
don't have a room and
over half of the students in my lab at
that time of women who did have wounds
and many of them have gone on to have
babies and still build robots themselves
I think they're glad theory I don't
quite buy that and so then the other
version is I you just want to be God I I
don't think that's the reason I you know
I didn't have lots of Cardinals in my
lab to count of that but or minor gods
who didn't need it and their therapists
have ever done residences at the lab to
sort of analyze you and Nora no but you
know I think it's it's it's it's why do
we why do we all want to explore the
unknown I mean different people explore
different aspects of the unknown
sometimes it's their own endurance
sometimes it's a you know particular
detail of some some particular science
this is the thing that drives me and I
find fascinating let's take another
question if there if there is one how
about from this side of the room Alan
thank you very much I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit about the
difference between
machines and robots because I guess you
know what makes my coffee machine a
machine and what makes the natto robot
and do my regular robot is it is it
personality or something else because
Scott rubber boats pop cultural
references even the rapid you talk about
yeah yeah for me the definition of a
robot is something that has sensors it
senses something about the world it does
some computation and then it acts in the
world some way so that the silicon
retina in your eye won't be a robot per
se but its robotic technology robotic
inspired technology sorry that we'd be
bringing into our bodies we will be the
robots with this augmentation of robotic
black technology the coffee machine
doesn't really take any interesting
action in the world and so for me that's
a not such an interesting robot but
actually in some countries traffic
lights are referred to as robots because
of that autonomous nature you know it's
a fuzzy line ultimately if coffee
machines had more intelligence in terms
of knowing well okay it's you know rod
is up it's six-fifteen in the morning
he's up earlier than usual but I better
start making the coffee and he didn't
get as much sleep last night so it's
going to be stronger coffee I mean can
you get a coffee machine to that yeah
but I think more likely what's going to
happen is with your wireless internet
connection you're going to wake up and
say get me some coffee you don't think
that and then the coffee machine will
respond to that through local networking
in your house okay let's take another
question yes right here in the front
third Grand most of the robots you
describe where program like the lawn
cutters and so they had a real domain
that they worked in an outsider but if
you're thinking of something more
general that has to respond to language
that we have to do a lot of work in
language understanding and context that
you would bring in speaking to a work on
yeah yeah that's nice restate the
question a little choice case it didn't
get caught robots understanding our
language and the context in which we
speak seems to be a big a big challenge
it is indeed and that's why I've said
that I don't think we're going to get
the super intelligent robots in our
lives in the short term we're going to
get these robots to do useful work which
don't need that in our lives and then
but the other thing that's going to
happen is we're going to be augmenting
our bodies because we do have that
intelligence we're going to be remotely
controlling robots using those
linguistic or visual cortex abilities I
don't think we're going to see a
commander data which is this fully
intelligent fully general robot in the
short term at all great standing right
here but leaving we've been talking
about in robotics the notion of
artificially constructed or artificial
intelligence or whatever you have
converging closer and closer to human
beings with the concept the arrogant
notion of course that they'll be better
than human beings in some sense faster
stronger smarter what have you and I
think during the 50s and the 60s and 70s
that was the dominant robotic concept
but biotechnology in the 90s have told
us about cloning and I want to talk I
want I want our guest speaker to talk
about cloning because that's the
convergence of human beings with robots
let's take some laboratory in some
non-us country where there's no
Constitution about
individual rights Japan needs them but
we won't choose Japan let's assume a
less ethical civilization or culture
where they clone people to be robots and
you want somebody who's really good at
violence so you take a piece from jascha
heifetz or somebody else and you clone a
jascha heifetz and you also take out of
the genetic pool kind of freewill
qualities because those are always
troublesome in in slave or servitude
society so you take out rebellion and
you take out obstruction and so you
develop a guy who on command if you will
plays mozart and doesn't complain with
Valerie I know colleagues it's a big
Asha I if its gene what can I tell you
that's actually a great question i guess
i would just let me restate it a little
bit and sort of tag something onto it
you know it's the boundaries between
cloning human beings in you know in the
Dolly the sheep fashion and building
robotic copies of human beings and also
the ethical issues of how will we treat
either these clones are these robot
Xerox copies of us well we have to treat
them as well well you know I'm not a bio
technologist but but I think there's a
little that this this is this question
and I think presupposes in a way that I
don't think is accurate this is cloning
was carbon copy cloning doesn't make
carbon copies cloning creates another
cat as CC recently appeared in science
or another sheep but it has to go
through development you don't you don't
get these fully formed doppelgangers
coming out of the VAT who can play
Mozart they have to study Mozart for 12
20 years they have to go to Juilliard
too and they might decide they want to
play electric guitar instead anything
they could exactly so I think I think I
think that level of I think that's the
the the Hollywood version of cloning
rather than any realistic version of
but I think that what I was trying to
make the point before was we are over
the next 50 years going to get control
over some biological processes we're
going to appropriate biological systems
and build on top of them in ways which
will raise all sorts of ethical
questions I don't think we're going to
be exactly that set of ethical questions
but there are going to be all sorts of
ethical questions that we're going to
have to face which i think will you know
will long for the good old days of the
stem cell debates because I think
they're going to be much harder over the
next 50 years then we're going to
continue to see difficult questions well
I mean it strikes me that you don't have
to make my real baby that much more
sophisticated before I would start
feeling bad about turning it off and
putting it out with the trash or
something like that oh no my customer if
you think it's the hottest I'm doing
hypersensitive some more questions I'm
how it right here in the front
that was upstairs with respect to
emotion and robotics
just as an example when we walked into
the room the robot had a tendency to
would that be considered antisocial
behavior and if and a few cornered in it
and there were no other options for it
would it be frustrated as a robot could
experience a range of frustration the
question is about a robot that was
around in the cocktail party before that
we started this fire side chat a robot
that was looking for free space and
where's the room got more crowded didn't
have anywhere to go I think as humans we
attribute intentional intentionality to
the machines even when they don't have
it I think we attribute intentionally
the people even when they don't have it
we even attribute intentionality to the
selves even when we don't have it that's
how we understand the world for me that
particular robot didn't have any real
frustrations b-but in the eye of the
observer maybe that's an easy way of
describing it as the models get more
sophisticated in the robots which that
robot had none of these emotional models
then I think not only to get easier for
the person described that way but it
becomes very accurate because the models
that a person then brings to what the
behavior that robot is going to be based
on these understanding of how emotions
than we work will become accurate and so
it really does become the best way to
understand it in the case of the robot
saw you tonight because it didn't have
any emotional model in there your
predictions based on your projection of
emotional state to it may have ended up
turning up to give you entirely wrong
predictions in certain circumstances so
future models when they get frustrated
about getting cornered they might run
over your toes or something like that
yeah actually if it was interesting you
know when we first in the 80s first
simple robots in the lab it was
interesting the way people how people
would react to the robots depending on
how fast they move if there was a robot
which went up the wall hit the wall
backed off slowly and then hit again
slowly people would say what a dumb
robot but if it fast they take all look
it's angry
same thing to be let's take some more
questions but Bruce in the back rod what
are the biggest technological hurdles
that you face in the humanoid
development that you've been working on
is it power supply circuitry software
where to where do you see the
breakthroughs avantika well let me let
me give him my favorite big breakthrough
problem that we need to solve we've been
working on computer vision for over 40
years and we've made a lot of progress
in the last three or four years about
tracking things as they move in real
time finding human faces recognizing
faces in the medical domain
understanding medical imagery because
all human bodies are essentially the
same but 40 years ago will allow the at
recognizing individual objects so you
take you know a cell phone take pair of
glasses you know a glass of water
playing a camera at this ask a computer
program to tell me what those objects
are 40 years ago we'll lousy at it ater
the PhD thesis on this and the late 70s
will lousy at it today our programs are
still lousy at it we must be missing
something deep I suspect and I think
that's the biggest impediment to making
the robots be more useful in everyday
environment because we have to to do
complex tasks we have to keep a person
in the loop with a visual cortex because
we can't make our robots do this general
object recognition let's take some more
questions right up front here Oliver
describe the entrenchment of the view of
what it is the quintessentially human
from having emotions back to pass with
having spirit and cheering spice that
vanish completely just saying you know
posturing testamentary difference so are
you worth doing in that sense where he
was so [ __ ] build oh I let me just
restate the question because the mic was
far away it's about the Turing test and
you'll have to explain a little bit
about the Turing test and I'm not
familiar with the other ok other side of
that argument ok so the Turing test Alan
Turing British mathematician late 40s
early 50s said that could develop this
hypothetical test that if you talked
over teletype a instant message as
something someone at the other end and
you can't tell whether it's a person or
a machine and indeed as a machine then
for all intents and purposes the machine
is as intelligent as a person if you
can't distinguish roughly and the
question is whether i ascribe to that
notion of intelligence or whether the
notion that John Searle states that says
you have to have the historical
background to the to the being even if
you know it can sound like a philosopher
can smell like a philosopher but unless
it's a philosopher it's not a
philosopher and I'm very much with will
Alan Turing there I think we will all
modulo the the the you know that there's
still a lot to do with language and
other aspects as the robots become more
intelligent we will start attributing
more to the man interacting with them as
though they are beings and start to
grant them parts of animal hood maybe
and ultimately parts of personhood in
the same way that we as a society over
the last 40 years in the US have started
granting parts of personhood to
chimpanzees and dolphins which we didn't
used to and 150 years ago you know the
English didn't certainly been grant
personhood to Africans that this
granting of personhood has extended
beyond the pure human being
now and will just naturally extend to at
some level two robots over time I think
we have time for one or two more
questions over there earlier at the very
beginning of your discussion you talking
about humans losing their specialness
and you know if you think about sort of
i think the holy grail of specialness
you know we talk about life as being a
miracle you know that's that's something
that you hear about all the time and you
started to touch about the touch on this
in your before we just opened up to
discussion about sort of what
constitutes life you talked about like
self repair and and regeneration has a
big subway yeah and i was just sort of
wondering you know at what point do you
how do you sort of deconstructed i
stacked what life is and how what makes
a machine a living thing because that
seems to be kind of a summary of all
these ethical arguments you know what
are we go what are we going to do or not
do with this living thing and so how do
you define a living thing if it's not
necessarily hundred percent organic or
even fits yeah so so what how do we
define something is living is the
question and that that's really what's
led me to my current research agenda
trying to answer that question because i
don't know the answer to that and you
know I came to that by trying to answer
well when would it really have emotions
when would it really be happy you'll
really be fearful not just appear to be
fearful appear to be happy and I reduced
it to this Crocs question what makes it
really alive whether it's made out of
biomolecules weather is it possible to
make it out of some other material and
that's I don't know whether we have the
pasta talk about some of the features of
life oh I was because I talked about
features of life because I don't run any
other way to attack the problem except
to go after some of these features and
then you know that third part I talked
about the graduate students having the
winding insights about what's really
important here I'm trying to set up an
environment where someone will have
those insights but it hasn't happened do
you mean it does the philosophy
department at MIT worry that you're sort
of encroaching on their turf I mean it
seems like you're asking something
question I don't think of a philosophy
the pop knows I existed it
man I I spent a lot of time without a
philosopher's from other places ah let's
take one last question here how about a
minute in the second right here and
there are two holdouts for the
specialness a few minutes that come to
my mind one is Joseph Campbell
talks about the unity
spirituality across all unit things and
then we worship a different religions
but he describes in the scientific
approach to spirituality and energy so
that says that's his position and he
claims that humans will never know their
spirituality which is why they worship
this unknown that it's just congenitally
impossible for a human to do that the
second person who's hold out for the
specialness of humans is Christopher
Alexander and he spent a lifetime trying
to define he's a mathematician and an
architect trying to defined in a
rigorous way what it is to be alive and
where it is be human and in that effort
he first he wasn't a carpet
rationalist view of the world and says
well this is one way to observe the
world this is a scientific method and we
can create how things work so that's a
mechanistic view of the world which i
think is what where we are with robotics
it's a mechanistic approximation of
emotion for example the second what how
standardized is said there's a second
way there's a second way to observe
nature and objectively as it's not just
as Descartes with from the cartesian
view all opinions and spirituality and
values are personal just opinions they
can't be objectively identified as
campbell would agree alexander's come up
with a methodology a way to observe
nature which defines with 15 properties
a way to identify alliance and in the
process spiritual value and aesthetic
value which sort of takes the motion to
another couple of levels so I offer that
I'd be curious to know I don't know that
particular piece of work I mean though
many books there are many I mean there's
lots of people who attack these problems
it's been a major question and I've read
many of them I haven't read either of
those particular authors but I'd be
happy to you know if you give me the
reference are we having to go and have a
look and when I was 23 million lifetime
three volumes okay we've we've got a
really big bottom tonight
has become programmers to help them
define tomorrow program and Alexandra
about that because I totally
misunderstood as well which is often I
should point out though I get about four
or five solutions to this per week by
email so well a lot to read yeah and
it's unfortunate that we can't offer the
solution right now although I'm starting
to think maybe the last you know the
last bastion of human specialness is
that I can tell the difference between
the eyeglasses and the cell rocks that
is that they that'll last for a while it
couldn't my little bit I i want to thank
you for coming to join us and i want to
thank the audience for being here and we
really have to just wrap this up because
I think we've already lost five or ten
pounds from sitting from a fireplace it
just can't take it anymore so thank you
all for kind
Rodney a Brooks is director of the
artificial intelligence laboratory at
MIT he's also chairman and chief
technology officer of irobot corporation
flesh and machines how robots will
change us is published by Pantheon books
visit Pantheon books calm for more
information